hey this is Mel strong in this lecture
is on El Nino and La Nina also known as
the El Nino Southern Oscillation or ENSO
so we're going to start today looking at
Earth nautical net and right now I'm
looking at the surface winds and I've
got a date a day here in the summer in
July and so we can see a couple things
here's the big Pacific subtropical high
swirling around out in the ocean there's
another high over there and these little
guys here are tropical storms of some
kind maybe they are hurricanes or maybe
not not sure and if we look down here we
can also see this funny-looking thing
here is also another subtropical high
it's not very symmetrical it's a weird
shape today but ok so what I'm going to
do is I'm going to look at sea surface
temperature so to do that I click the
word earth mode is ocean animate
currents overlay SST for sea surface
temperature okay so the colors now
represent what we call the skin
temperature of the ocean so this is the
temperature of the ocean water right at
the surface and we can actually measure
this we've got satellites up that
measure this every day and so the colors
represent temperatures you might expect
and so a couple things we can see for
one thing we can see there's a band of
pretty warm temperatures not exactly at
the equator but kind of around the
equator so if I could just kind of zoom
out all right so we've got a band of
pretty warm temperatures near the
equatorial region but it's not very
symmetrical okay so for example over
here this purple that's even warmer than
the red so you've got this pool of
really warm water kind of over here in
the western part of the Pacific Basin
and then there's this weird thing where
right at the equator it's actually kind
of cooler than the water around it which
is maybe not what you would expect now
if I look around here let's look at the
Pacific Basin so notice that if I were
to pick say a certain line of latitude
and go straight across stick at this
line at latitude right here that over on
the eastern side of the Pacific Ocean
it's colder than it is on the western
side right so you can see this greenish
yellow color coming down here whereas if
I just pick one line of latitude like
that spot right there
and go all the way across it's much much
warmer on the western side than the
eastern side so something is causing the
ocean to be asymmetric in terms of
temperature that there's something
that's dragging colder water down from
the north and allowing this warm water
to kind of come up from the south okay
and if I look at the southern basin I
see kind of the same thing
I see cooler water that is being pulled
up here to the north and I see warmer
water over here to the west it's not
symmetrical
and if I move over to the Atlantic I see
something kind of similar
I've got cooler water up here or more
water down there and up here somewhere
again cooler water down there warmer
water up here so the ocean basins are
not symmetrical in their temperature so
the first question is why is that okay
why would it be colder over here and
warmer over here so the answer is that
just a minute ago we saw that there are
big clockwise winds out here in the
Pacific the Pacific is a subtropical
high and then over here in the Atlantic
another one big again it's not perfectly
shaped on on this particular day and of
course they go counterclockwise and
the Pacific I'm sorry in the in the
southern hemisphere so you've got the
subtropical highs that are just spinning
around and around and around all day
long every day out in the ocean and the
wind blows the ocean so the reason we
have ocean currents for the most part is
wind the reason we have waves is wind
wind is what's pushing the ocean around
and so when we look at this temperature
so I'll go again
ocean currents SST that is the result of
the Pacific subtropical high blowing the
ocean towards the south blowing this
colder water down towards the equator
and down here same thing except instead
of going clockwise it's going
counterclockwise so you've got winds
blowing cold water towards the north so
one of the things that these subtropical
highs do is they help bring cold water
from up here down towards the equator
and they take warm water from the
equator and bring it up towards the
poles and they do that in both
hemispheres so they help mix up colder
and warmer water okay so I've got a
little map here of the world and so in
general what we would notice is that so
so before I start this is I kind of
sketched in the equator here there's a
big loop that's out in the ocean
big circulation pattern and it kind of
looks like this and down here it looks
like this and those loops are being
caused by the subtropical highs and in
the you know it's swirling the ocean
around in the giant circle and that
giant circle is called a gyre so the the
big circulation pattern that we see in
the ocean basins is as big clockwise and
then counterclockwise rotation of the
ocean caused by the Pacific's or the
subtropical highs just spinning and
spanning and span
okay so that's a primary feature that we
see well let's add a few more things to
this now what we know is that near the
equator we have the ITCZ right if you
remember back to that what's happening
at the ITCZ we've got easterlies what
are they doing they're converging so I'm
gonna sketch that in a little bit so all
along here I have easterly's that are
coming together now remember we said in
a past or yeah in the past lecture that
the convergence isn't exactly at the
equator that it moves around with the
seasons okay so I'm drawing this to be
along the equator just to show it to
make a point here but remember this
exact spot changes with the seasons
okay so there's our easterly's okay so
let's just think about that for a minute
if you had wind blowing from from east
to west this direction and it's blowing
along the top of the ocean what it's
going to do is it's going to basically
skim the warmest part of the water and
push it towards the west so let's
imagine like if you're in a swimming
pool and you start doing this to the top
of the water with your hand you scoot
that water along the out of the surface
of the pool same things happening here
so as a result we end up taking this
warm water because this is near the
equator so it's going to be some of the
warmest water in the ocean at least it
should be and we're gonna shove it this
direction and what's going to happen is
that really warm water pools up over
here okay so that's what we're seeing
over here so this purple blob this is
all really warm water that's kind of
been shoved over from the from the east
it's blown across the ocean so if I look
at my easterlies let's look at my okay
so there's
there's my easterlies okay right there
so those are winds and the winds are
just kind of pushing that warm water
across the equal equatorial zone you see
they're going and today that's a little
curvy there but they're coming this
direction and they kind of die out on
this particular day but they're they're
pooling this really warm water over here
but I buy all these island nations go
back to this again okay so there it is
at purple water that's the warmest part
of the ocean there's always a pool of
just really warm and may feel like bath
water if you got into it okay so I'm
going to add that to my drawing and I'm
just going to kind of approximate that
out in here there's this pool of very
warm water right and the boundaries are
always changing but it's just kind of
over here okay so if you're if you're
removing water from this part of the
ocean then there has to be some other
water that comes up and takes its place
okay so that's part of the story here
that if I remove the warm water you're
gonna have to replace it with something
else
now the something else happens to
coincide with a place where there is
this big Bend
okay so right here where the where the
the gyre is making a turn by the
continent imagine it's like you're
pulling water away from the continent so
I'm just going to kind of draw some
arrows to show that I'm pulling water
away from the continent like this
alright so if I'm if I'm moving water
across the ocean here and then pulling
water away from the continent here we
need to produce more water to replace
the water that's being pulled away and
it turns out the water that that comes
in to replace it comes up from near the
bottom of the ocean
that's called upwelling so all along
here all along here and all along here
there is water that's coming up from the
bottom of the ocean
okay I'm gonna draw that in blue I'm
gonna call this up Welling so what's the
water at the bottom of the ocean like
it's very close to the freezing point
now because of all the pressure it
doesn't actually freeze down there but
there's places at the bottom of the
ocean that are actually at about zero
degrees Celsius or 32 Fahrenheit that's
at the freezing point it's just not
frozen so that water comes up to the
surface and is really really cold so
this is also a shock to anybody who has
tried to go swimming in Southern
California so right so for example la is
somewhere kind of like right in here and
if I go across and latitude you're
somewhere over here on the East Coast
right if you went swimming out here it's
pretty Pleasant it's nice and warm if
you go exact cold the same latitude and
come over here and go swimming off the
coast of let's say Los Angeles or San
Diego you find out it's actually really
cold and this shocks tourists because
they think about Southern California and
sunny and there's surfers and all this
and they get out in the ocean like holy
crap it's cold because that water was
actually just recently at the bottom of
the ocean and it's coming up to the
surface as is all along this part of
South America okay this is all deep cold
water coming to the surface okay
well it turns out that besides the water
being cold it has a lot of nutrients in
it things die out in the ocean and as a
little things die and they fall down
that kind of sets up a food chain when
that water comes back up to the surface
it's got nutrients in it little
microorganisms eat that and bigger
things eat the microorganism and so on
and so forth and tell you finally you
get to fish and so the fish actually
most of the fish in the ocean live near
the continents in
zones with the cold upwelling water the
fish like the cold water it has all the
things that they want to eat in it and
so most of the fish Fisheries in the
world are kind of up in here up here and
other places were where this happens
okay so go back a few thousand years and
you've got people that are living all up
and down South America okay so you have
to imagine in what's now modern-day
Chile and Peru people living up and down
the coasts now we didn't really talk
about this at the time but when we
talked about rainshadow the there are
the Andes that are right along in here
let me just sketch that out real quick
so the Andes are mountain chain right
through here and they're very you know
it's a tall chain of volcanoes and the
storms that come in come in this
direction so a storm that comes in dumps
its rain in the Amazon basin and goes up
and up and up and up and up and up and
then goes downhill on the other side and
this is a very extreme rain shadow
okay there's there are areas here it
literally has not rained in over ten
years okay some of it's called the
Atacama Desert you may have heard of
that
so these early people that lived along
the coast here if you want protein you
really only have one option and that's
to get fish because this so dry is
really hard to grow much of anything
so fishing became a livelihood for all
the people that lived here and they kept
records so for those people that lived
along this west coast of South America
you had to make your living as a
fisherman okay that was just the way it
was well they noticed once in a while
they would go out in their boats and
this would happen maybe kind of around
Christmastime near the end of the year
and they would go out and they would
notice that actually this zone right in
here the water was unusually warm right
through here and they would notice
the fish were gone and this was a
disaster because they depended on the
fish and the fish wanted the cold water
in the cold water had disappeared and
they didn't know what causes this but
they all they seemed to notice that this
often seemed to happen when he got close
to Christmas and they called this event
El Nino and El Nino for them bad news
because once they once they encountered
this warm water and the lack of fish
this was gonna last for months and as
possible people were going to starve
because he couldn't catch fish maybe for
six months or more this is where the
name El Nino comes from and they named
it that because of association with time
of year at Christmas and baby Jesus and
all that good stuff and so that's where
El Nino actually gets its name so what
caused that now what we now know today
and they did not know this back then is
that something is going to shut this
whole circulation system down the Easter
bees are gonna die the easterlies die
the warm water moves back across the
ocean as the mourn water moves back
across the ocean the upwelling dies when
the upwelling dies the cold water stops
coming to the surface when the cold
water stops coming to the surface the
fish go somewhere I don't know exactly
where they go but they but they leave
that's El Nino so to explain this I'm
going to show a couple animations that
explain what an El Nino event looks like
so this is a simple little animation
that just explains first we're going to
look at what I just talked about which
is not El Nino not Lenina but just a
normal condition so here is going to
show this is a cross-section through the
ocean and the warm part of the water is
this upper part and here's our
easterlies also known as the trades and
they're blowing from east to west
and they're gonna pull up the warm water
over here and you're going to get rising
air because you got this big pool of
warm water and that's going to create a
relatively low pressure and so that's
what they're showing here and a lot of
precipitation rains over here every day
and there is also air kind of sinking
back out here that's making it high and
this is called the Walker circulation
cell now what they're trying to show
here are those coastal winds from the
gyre coming up the coast and here's the
upwelling so they're trying to show the
here comes that cold water and it comes
up to the surface and then it gets
pushed along the equator here and then
you have this pool of relatively warm
water over here now the animator got
this wrong because you saw that the the
warm water it started creeping in from
the west over here which is not right we
said that the warm water was pushed
across the ocean this way so they got
that wrong but this is kind of to show
what I I just talked about there should
be not just cold water along the coast
but a little bit along the equator here
okay so we can see this I go back okay
so now we're back to what kind of sea
surface temperatures alright so notice
this you've got this yellow this cooler
water and there's this ribbon of yellow
kind of along the equator that's cooler
water that's being pulled up from the
upwelling the upwelling is happening
down here and then it's being kind of
pulled along with the easterlies you can
see the direction of the currents here
being essentially pushed pushed to the
to the west over here so that's why it's
weird that you've got some of the
coldest water around here is right along
the equator where you'd expect it to be
the warmest because the winds are
pushing this cold water along here okay
so that's our upwelling so I'm going to
add that to our diagram
so we've got this ribbon of cool water
kind of like in here which are just
shade so just to be clear we've got cool
water along the coast we got cool water
along the coast down here and the
easterlies are pushing that along the
equator so we have this ribbon a fairly
cold air okay so this is not El Nino
this is a normal year okay alright so
now we're going to go back to the
animation okay so this is where we left
off the animation so let's see what
happens in an El Nino so the El Nino
animation is gonna start from this point
which is a normal year okay so here we
are now what happens is those winds the
Tradewinds the easterlies they die down
for some reason and in fact they might
even reverse and so the ocean starts to
slosh back across the equator this big
pool of warm water works its way back
across the ocean that upwelling stops
and instead of having cold water here
and cold water along the equator you
have relatively warm water also that
these two pressure centers reversed so
now you've got more of a low pressure
over here and more of a high pressure
over here so these guys are now
relatively dry and these guys are
relatively wet so this whole system that
is now referred to as El Nino so trade
winds or easterly's die warm water
sloshes back across the ocean upwelling
stops you've got warm water along this
coast on this coast and along the
equator we didn't have it before that's
El Nino
now what's La Nina aw Nina we're gonna
start again from a normal year so this
is a normal year and what happens in a
La Nina is that the trade winds get
stronger
so this is their showing the arrows here
getting kind of fatter so the wind is
blowing the the easterlies I was blowing
harder than they were this makes more
upwelling than we used to have that
blows the cold water further along the
equator towards the west and you'll see
that this pool of warm water shrinks a
little bit and this pool of cold water
grows a little bit that's a long mean
iya condition now we know from these
from these chili and fishermen and they
kept records for I don't remember how
far back but several hundred years that
this is a naturally occurring thing so
this was happening on earth long before
humans were having any effect on the
climate and it would happen maybe every
five or six or seven years they would
have one of these El Nino events and so
it's a naturally occurring thing and for
the most part we can't really predict it
the way we predict it is we actually
have if I go back to my El Nino here so
I deposit so if an El Nino is coming and
we have some like ships out here our
buoys with thermometers in them or maybe
we can see this from satellites we can
watch we can notice that when this warm
water starts to creep across the ocean
right so if an El Nino is going to
happen we can we can detect this warm
water on the move before it actually
gets to the coast so we can predict it
that way but we have no way of saying oh
next years in El Nino or the year after
that as an El Nino we can't we can't do
that is this is not a predictable
process when an El Nino happens it
happens
several this condition lasts for several
months so it's not really weather and
it's not really climate it's kind of in
between right it's a little bit it kind
of bridges the gap between climate and
weather it's a process that occur that
will change the weather for several
months at a time
so El Nino is one of the two phases was
the other being Lonnie Nia we generally
refer to both of these two together as
ENSO El Nino Southern Oscillation
the Southern Oscillation refers to these
two pressure centers that swapped so
again this right here this is a well
we've a normal year not El Nino not La
Nina we've got a lo over here we've got
a hi over here and in the El Nino one of
the things that happened is that these
two pressure centers swapped places
that's what we call the Southern
Oscillation okay that's what it refers
to and we're not going to get too deep
in this class about what all that means
except to say that that's what the name
comes from so they'll hear this term and
so when you hear and so just think El
Nino and La Nina together like it
changes between one and the other from
year to year but collectively we just
called this thing in soul so before we
move on to the effects that El Nino has
on our weather I want to point out a
couple other things with the SST maps so
when we talk about El Nino La Nina
events is only happening in the Pacific
Ocean so apparently the Atlantic Ocean
is too small now it has there's
something similar going on here there's
some upwelling here there's you can see
this ribbon of cool water along the
equator here but when we talk about Long
Nina and El Nino events it doesn't
really seem to affect the Atlantic Ocean
it's only the Pacific Ocean where all
this stuff happens
yeah thing I want to point out is we
also have some interesting ocean
currents in our part of the world so
here's the Gulf of Mexico and again this
is a day in the summer so we have
especially warm water here in the Gulf
of Mexico and I want you to notice this
this stream this current coming out of
the Gulf that's called the Gulf Stream
and if we kind of fall or it goes
there's this ribbon of warm water that
there's a bunch of Eddie's and stuff and
it makes its way across the Atlantic
Ocean and if I kind of look at the big
scale here really warm water is coming
out of the Gulf of Mexico comes up the
East Coast
and it heads out to sea and it ends up
actually over here by Europe so this
part of the ocean right here it's see
it's relatively kind of yellow in color
compared to over here where you've got
this colder green and blue colors so
this part of the ocean is being kept
warmer because there is a current of
warm water that's basically stealing our
warm water from the Gulf of Mexico and
pumps it out here and dumps it out in
this part of the ocean now this is
important because for people that live
in Europe if you think about the related
to it here right right right here if you
follow this line of latitude across okay
you're in the that would be equivalent
to the middle of the United States what
if you went up say to this one
okay so there's UK and all that there
follow this one across and you're in
Canada right so what's what are the
winners like in this in the middle of
Canada well very very cold but they're
not nearly so cold over here in Europe
even though it's the same latitude why
because this body of water that this
part of the Atlantic Ocean is warmer
than it would be if it wasn't for the
Gulf Stream the Gulf Stream takes this
warm water brings it up dumps into this
part of the ocean keeps Europe warmer
than the normally would be in fact if
you shut this off somehow Europe would
be much much colder in fact it would it
would look similar to what it looked
like in the last ice age so when we get
to climate change which is a couple
weeks away one of the things we're going
to talk about is the possibility that
this stream might shut down and if it
shuts down that's going to make Europe a
whole lot colder okay so that's a little
counter
to ative when we talk about the worth
getting warmer why could why could
Europe suddenly get colder has to do
with this I just want to point it out
now because that's what we're talking
about so if we have an El Nino or La
Nina event we can get some really
radical changes in the weather and ocean
temperatures depending on where you live
so for example these guys are catching
tropical fish off the coast of Southern
California now we just said that the
water off the coast of California is
really cold because it's from the bottom
of the ocean but during it El Nino that
up whittling stops in that warm water
sloshes back across the ocean and the
tropical fish follow of that and so
these guys are catching tropical fish in
a place which normally really cold water
a lot of times animals just can't handle
the changes in water temperature so
these are zillions of dead crabs that
couldn't handle the warmer water of El
Nino and again we were in California
they washed ashore here by the millions
and you gotta wonder how bad this smells
after a few days of this but during an
El Nino that sudden change in
temperature can really kill a lot of
animals that are that have adapted to
growing in an environment with you know
pretty cold water like I said it's
usually not - not too much warmer than
freezing most of the time and suddenly
you have this warm tropical water and a
lot of animals can't handle that now
the El Nino event itself or La Nina is
affecting this area right near the ocean
or near the equator and you'd expect
well the the weather through here will
probably be different because of this
but what you may not expect is that this
a change in an event down here triggers
all kinds of changes of weather all over
the world so here's a map showing the
types of weather changes that occur
during an El Nino and in the winter so
December January February so just to
reiterate when we have an El Nino or La
Nina it lasts for several
okay so it may last six months or eight
months or four months and so during that
time it will have effects on the weather
so for example you may not be able to
quite quite read the key down here but
along the equator it says warm and wet
okay that makes sense in a nil ninu
you've got warm water sloshing across
that should make it warmer and give you
more precipitation but then for example
up here it says it's going to be warmer
or warmer and drier or places where the
precipitation increases and notice
what's happening over here we've got a
green zone that says wetter that we've
got a kind of a bluer zone that says
cool and wet so this change here is
affecting things all over the planet and
for us as in New Mexico wearing this
green blob so we're going to explain
that in a little bit
now here's El Nino June July August and
notice that we see some changes in
different parts of the world right so
down here it's cool and dry or
what-have-you but notice that for the
most part not much as changing in North
America in general and especially not in
the United States so for us if we have
an El Nino it affects our winter
precipitation in our winter temperatures
and we'll talk more about that in a
second does not seem to affect us in the
summer okay so keep that in mind that El
Nino really affects our winter time if
we have a log in yeah again that's gonna
make this you know the definition of La
Nina is the is the winds here or
blooming stronger from the east which
makes this colder okay so if it's colder
you'd expect to be cooler and drier that
makes sense but it also has effects all
over the world so for example up in here
it says it's making it wetter and down
here it's making it drier okay and so
we're also you know we're kind of
getting up here here in New Mexico or
it's gonna have some kind
for us to which we'll talk about in a
second so the point is you're only
changing this but somehow it's having
effects all over the planet
so why might this be the situation Owen
before I forget if I look at anemia
again in the summer we see really
nothing changing here in the United
States
okay so El Nino or La Nina doesn't
really affect our summer weather at
least not that we've been able to
determine does affect our winter weather
so how is it that the change in the
temperature along down here by the
equator can have effects all over the
planet short answer is it's really
complicated but there's one thing that
we can learn about in this class that
we've talked about before so we talked
about the polar front right so let's
imagine the polar front is going kind of
feel like this on a normal year so to
remind you the cold air is up here the
warmer is down here in the middle
latitude cyclones basically follow this
path and that's always changing right
there's these curves and the whole thing
we've talked about with the rows be
waves but in general the storms are kind
of coming in through this direction now
let's say we have an El Nino so an El
Nino means that we have warmer than
usual temperatures here and here and
here all right this is in an El Nino
warmer than normal
okay so I just write this out here okay
so in an El Nino event it's warmer than
normal now the the fact that there is a
pool of warmer water here will cause the
polar front to shift positions a little
bit and it will actually shift a little
further to the south
I'm exaggerating this greatly just to
make a point
so the polar front shifts a little
further south during an El Nino winter
than a normal winter so if we think
about mid latitude cyclones right the
mid-latitude cyclones are forming along
the polar front where are they going to
go well during an El Nino because the
polar front shifts further south then
the mid-latitude cyclones shift further
south so what that means is in a non El
Nino year just a normal year you'd
expect the mid-latitude cyclones to kind
of be following say the path of the
Green Line coming up into the Pacific
Northwest but an El Nino year this whole
thing will be shifted down and the
Pacific sub I'm sorry the mid-latitude
cyclones will be traveling further south
well what's further south of this Green
Line well we are so US as in New Mexico
we'll be in a position where we are more
likely to get mid-latitude cyclones than
in a normal non El Nino year okay so
this is gonna have an effect on our
weather because it's shifting the polar
front south okay so let's look at a
couple maps here so here is a couple of
cartoons to try to illustrate this and
they're using some slightly different
terminology than what we've been using
so so far we've been talking about the
Jetstream and one type of polar front is
actually it splits there's more than one
type of jet I don't want to get too deep
into this but what they're trying to
show here is in an El Nino this
Jetstream what I'm calling the polar
front is bringing in storms kind of
right through here within this orange
line which is going to make this area
wetter than normal in this area warmer
and drier than normal
so the storms that we're coming up here
are now coming further south in a La
Nina the opposite happens in a La Nina
the jet polar the polar front again is
shifted further to the north so it's
exactly the opposite and the storms tend
to go further to the north and skip us
more often so we end up to be drier and
they end up to be wetter okay so what
we're doing is we're shifting the
location of where those mid-latitude
cyclones come in in an El Nino they tend
to come further south they make us
wetter in a La Nina it's in to go
further north make us drier so that's
going to have an effect on our overall
winter weather so this is a new type of
map we haven't seen in this class yeah
it's called an anomaly map anomaly means
something that's different than normal
so these colors this is a says composite
precipitation anomalies and what they've
done is they've every time there was an
El Nino they looked at all the
precipitation records for that El Nino
event and they compared it to what the
average precipitation was in the past
okay so what they've noticed is that the
places that are blue so it says five
case what does that mean that means that
during the winter voices that are dark
blue on average got five inches of
precipitation more than they normally
would that's an anomaly
whereas places that are say yellow or
orange got - one - two - three inches
from normal so this isn't telling you
how much precipitation they received
it's telling you how much extra or how
much less they got than what they
normally expect right so everyone
everybody that's in on this side and
these green and aqua colors are getting
more precipitation
than a normal year you know see that New
Mexico is right in here so we get about
one inch more than normal during an El
Ninos again this is spread out
throughout the whole winter right why is
that because the mid-latitude cyclones
are being directed further south so they
come in they dumped a lot in California
then they kind of moved downstream
towards us and we pick up some of that
extra precipitation now these guys are
in the red you can see the - three -
four - five inches these guys are
getting less precipitation than they
normally would because the storms that
used to come in here are now shifted
further south so weather El Nino is good
or bad depends on where you live let's
say you're a skier right well if your
skier in New Mexico you're happy when
they'll Nino happens we get more snow if
you're a skier in Washington State
you're sad when El Nino happens because
you have less snow now this is an
anomaly map so this is different than
average so it does not mean the red does
not mean that they are drier than we are
this is Washington state right so we get
eight inches of precipitation a year in
Albuquerque they get like 120 something
like that this is saying that there's
five inches less than their normal but
their normal is way bigger than our no
more our normal so keep in mind this
doesn't mean that they're dry and we're
wet that means they're drier than normal
this means we're wetter than normal okay
so that's how you read an anomaly map so
temperature-wise there can be there is a
difference - so if this if the
mid-latitude cyclones are coming further
south and they're going across the
southern United States we're gonna have
more cloudy days and that's going to
lower the temperature a couple of
degrees these guys are gonna have more
sunny days and so they're gonna have
temperatures a couple degrees greater
than average right so in an El Nino
winter again all these maps are for
winter
does not seem to affect our summer we
have a wetter than normal winter we have
a cooler than normal winter these guys
have a drier than normal winter and a
warmer than normal winter for an El Nino
La Nina everything's flipped almost so
the storms are concentrated to come up
and here more than they do and they miss
us almost completely and so here we have
you know negative 1 negative 2 negative
3 inches again over the whole winter
that's that would be 1 2 or 3 inches
less than what we normally get
so if you notice so so Albuquerque is in
this one right here and that's somewhere
between negative 2 and negative 3 inches
so that means that during a lawn Nino
winter we expect 2 to 3 inches below
normal precipitation
well how much precipitation do we
normally get throughout the whole winter
in New Mexico maybe like two inches so
two inches minus two is zero so when we
have a long Nina it often often results
in the winter that's almost completely
dry so we in the southwest hate anaemia
because it means the area of the country
that's already really dry
remember that Pacific subtropical high
we've been talking about makes this
whole area desert well in a Lonnie Mia
winter it gets worse because now the
storms are missing us even more than
often they're going up here and we're
even drier again weaken it
there are winters on record where it
literally did not produce any measurable
precipitation during the la Nino on the
other hand these guys are getting footed
because now they're getting way more
storms and they normally get they're
already used to a lot of precipitation
because it's Pacific Northwest but now
they're getting even more so you can see
they're getting you know excess of 5
inches above what they normally expect
for their winter now there's a
temperature anomaly but it doesn't quite
match up like you might expect in
general this part of the country is
warmer than
in Oh anemia you might think we would be
too but for some reason it doesn't ever
seem to work out that way so most of New
Mexico's temperatures don't change that
much with a la anemia but up in the
Pacific Northwest and actually all these
northern states up here are usually
having cooler than normal winter
temperatures so we're going to look at
another use of the anomaly map and this
is says weekly average sea surface
temperature anomaly so what that means
is everywhere that's the yellow and
orange and red colors correspond the
places where the ocean is warmer than it
normally is so for this location it's
warmer than average
what's average usually 30 years places
that are blue are cooler than their
average so realize how you have to
interpret an anomaly map right here is a
blob of water that's warmer than their
average right here a blob of water
that's cooler than their average but
this is that part of the ocean I said
was always the warmest part right so the
pool of water right here is really
really warm all the time
it's always going to be warmer than
whatever is down here so you can't get
confused and think that oh this is
warmer because it's more orange no no
that means it's warmer than average and
this is cooler than average but their
average is still way warmer than theirs
okay so you can't compare direct
temperatures in an anomaly map you can
only look at differences from average
okay so we're in 1982 this was a El Nino
year and this is gonna become an
animation and you're gonna see the weeks
click by and what we're looking for are
colors around the equator here that show
that the ocean is warmer than average
and if we see that we know we have an El
Nino ok so watch right in here and you
see those orange colors come and go
right there that's the El Nino right
through here so that's a location in the
ocean that's far warmer
normal that's what happens during an El
Nino because the up lowing shuts off
okay
a similar situation now our 1999 this is
a La Nina and we can see the Von Nina
occurring already it's this dark blue
color so that's where places that's
where the ocean is colder than normal
and so in a La Nina we expect exactly
the opposite that what we just saw we
expect to see blue colors along here and
you can watch when start the animation
you can watch how it'll kind of grow
back and forth here along the equator
okay so there's the the blue goes away a
little bit comes back a little bit so
this is one La Nina event right through
there okay so the ocean can go back and
forth between El Nino and La Nina from
year to year and a lot of years is not
in either one and so there's been some
attempts to try to describe how strong
an El Nino or La Nina is and so here's
one example it's called the ocean Nino
index also known as the El Nino index or
the ENSO index so here is so on the
x-axis we have time right so this is
January 2004 January 2005 each one of
these marks is another year okay so if
you have one of these Peaks that's on
the the red part of the graph that was
an El Nino if you have a peak in the
blue part of the graph that's a La Nina
and the higher the peak the stronger
event so this is a very strong El Nino
right here this is a very strong El Nino
right here these would be considered El
Ninos but they're pretty weak these are
pretty strong long Nina's and these are
pretty weak ones so a lot of years if
you have a little peak like that one or
that one or that one
you'd be say this is an in so neutral
year it's a little bit and the long mean
they're a little bit in the El Nino
direction but not enough to count in
some way years you've got these weak
Vence and then some years we have these
strong events and some years we have a
couple years in a row of the same thing
so for example here there was one winter
which was in El Nino and then the next
year after that even stronger El Nino so
think about what that would do for New
Mexico's precipitation El Nino year wet
winter right
so we likely had two winners in a row
that had an above average precipitation
on the other hand look at what happened
here La Nina
anemia and then really wimpy La Nina
followed after that but this whole time
in here the ocean is in a La Nina State
wanyan yeah dry winter so we're looking
at two or three or maybe four years in a
row where New Mexico would have had an a
winter with below average precipitation
and for us that's a big deal you got dry
winter after dry winter after dry winter
it adds up and you've got yourself you
you're in a drought at that point
you